Ragazzi e benvenuti in questo nuovo video
Oggi parleremo di capelli infatti mi avete chiesto in tantissimi dei consigli, su uno delle pettinature delle acconciature per le vostre feste
Quindi ho pensato di proporvi quattro opzioni che secondo me sono
carine sono facili da realizzare ma soprattutto sono
D'effetto partiamo subito. Dalla prima che secondo me è la più semplice
Da fare che sono semplici da fare, proprio semplicissimi e non ci crederete neanche da quanto e' semplice tutto quello che vi serve per questa pettinatura è un elastico
e voi direte cos'è una coda
Esatto è una coda ma attenzione con un piccolo trucchetto diventa una coda un po più particolare un po più elegate un po più carina
vediamo subito come realizzarla allora tutto quello che dovete fare quindi è una semplice coda bassa
Vi volete aiutare con la spazzola per tirare bene. I capelli
e fate la vostra codina
e voi direte tutto qui
aspetto adesso faccio vedere questo adesso mi giro per farvi vedere esattamente cosa dovete fare tutto quello che dovete fare è semplicemente
Allentare un pochino il vostro elastico di modo che si crei uno spazio tra la testa appunto è
Elastico
Dopo di ciò create un buchino proprio qui in mezzo vedete così e non dovete far altro che
sciare la vostra codina
all'interno di questo buco per poi stringerla bene
Questa è
la codeina caviglione fuori vedete che secondo me è molto molto elegante molto carina e molto sobria
Quelle meno sobri e le facciamo violanti è
Perfetta secondo me per io la farei per la cena di natale con parenti sarà un po più passata un po più formale
passiamo alla seconda
acconciatura si tratta di uno chignon
Ci servirà questo casino che non mi ricordo mai. Come si chiami però
Quello per fare il fascino e la lattea delle forcine e
un elastico
Anche qui poca roba allora questo chignon lo
posizionerei a un'altezza media perché quello poi più alto lo facciamo dopo
Quindi prendiamo se volete io tipo di lancio per mi piacciono lasciamo
2 su fettine avanti così
E andiamo con la cena repen. I fratelli per fare non. Ho il nostro raccolto un altezza di ray qui
Dopo di ciò
Prendiamo il nostro così no e ci
facciamo passare dentro la coda vedete
poi
Apriamo bene, I capelli ma che coprono tutto sul pollino e poi giriamo intorno
E poi fissarli bene con degli invisibili o delle forcine allora qui adesso non me li cioè, si possono tenere sia così va
Bè lisci adesso non mi sono passate. La piazza quindi. Le punte sono un po così
Oppure volendo si possono anche girare stile boccolo la punta un po più
insomma mossa il raccolto è anche questo molto elegante molto
classico è
Adattissimo secondo me qualsiasi cena di natale ma anche perché no il capodanno se andate insomma un capodanno un po più
come posso dire sobrio
classic
quindi non al mio per la terza acconciatura potete lasciar perdere
Il cosino e prendere il cotone
cosa ne pensate
questo sì che è un signor chignon
Allora sarà macine o molto alto
Possiamo sia lasciare I giusti come come abbiamo fatto prima ciuffetti giu oppure in questo caso vi farò vedere
Insomma I capelli tutti tirati indietro quindi molto molto
bon ton
sono pettinature comunque tutte molte bolton
Quindi la coda sarà come abbiamo detto paella alta più alta. La fase meglio
allora ecco la nostra quota prendiamo il nostro cotone e
Come abbiamo fatto prima insomma facciamo, lo stesso procedimento
Ed è subito sì sì la principessa allora andiamo come prima
fissare bene il nostro figlio
Mi sento molto evita di rivombrosa
Ok il problema quando uno realtà e filtro signor però chiaramente vedete che bisogna sistemare
Questa zona quindi direi un vertecchi
Pettinino un bel po di lancio detto, io adesso non abbonderà chiaramente perché sono poi dopo non riesco a fare presso
Tirate bene bene bene
Così
Poi se mi danno al sito come nel mio caso queste
Diciamo I capelli un po più radi vicino alla calzatura possiamo andare con
Un ombretto del colore, I nostri capelli oppure. Nel mio caso io uso la palette. Del contouring
andiamo leggermente a riempire questi buchini vedete senza chiaramente
esagerare giusto per
Non fare proprio vedere la netta differenza
Come vedete con questi tetti mini e la lacca andiamo a fissare bene
E il gioco è fatto questo è il nostro magazine
Che a questo punto direi forse per la cena in famiglia un po too much quindi magari per il capodanno
Ed eccoci arrivati alla quarta ed ultima
Non acconciatura perché acconciatura più una piega è una piega mossa che io realizzo spesso quindi oggi ve la propongo e
Diciamo che all'inizio non è facilissima da fare ce di prendere un po la mano
Tra l'altro io non. So se con tutte le piastre si possa realizzare
Io ho la ghd che ha fatto apposta sia per lisciare che per insomma fare questo mosso partiamo subito
chiaramente ha fatto scaldare una piastra serve la piastra una pinza e
Legge software prima di passare la piastra vi consiglio come ho fatto io di mettere
una protezione termica
Finito per la piastra una sorta di primer per I capelli e partiamo subito allora cercherò di spiegarvi
Come fare allora dovete prendere la piastra
e
Girarla lo so che cali se non vi verrà molto facile girarla in questo modo
Sì. Lo so sembra facile però mi ricordo all'inizio quando la vedevo fare
da mio parrucchiere
Volontà è una cavolata poi la facevo io e non mi veniva quindi come vi
Ho detto prima dovete esercitarvi un attimo però una volta che premi insomma la mano è
molto molto semplice quindi d'andata giro
Proseguo tengono lì perché
Si formi il mosso ed ecco qua
Se siete ricci come meri consiglio soprattutto vicino all'attaccatura di insistere un poker di
piastra re diciamo l'attaccatura per poi proseguire insomma col boccolo però almeno non rischiate che ci sia
il mosso sotto e il riccio all'attaccatura è tremendo siamo quasi arrivati
alla fine
Ok è mosso sia chiaramente io vi. Consiglio di andare a testa in giù così
Abbondare con la latta
Tornare ad essa in su e
Buon natale il gioco è fatto, il mosso c'è il volume pure
questo potete usare diciamo sempre cioè
e meno particolare rispetto agli altri senza una piega e potete farvi tutti I giorni un bel bossolo via di mezzo e
Siete pronti per le vostre feste
fatemi sapere qua sotto con un commento quale di queste pettinature vi è piaciuta
Di più quale magari volete provare a realizzare magari per una cena di natale percorso dopo danni e
niente come al solito se vi è piaciuto il video cliccate mi piace e
iscrivetevi al canale sono andati ancora fatto eseguite in su tutti gli altri social instagram facebook e il desiderio